hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from sorry about that from
round six of the 2019 Schanker chess
tournament it's the Kashima Memorial
Magnus Crossan is in the lead after five
rounds yesterday was the rest day
they've been playing some football
they've been you know having some
activities and now it's time to continue
as it usually is after a rest day either
all games will be drawn or there will be
fireworks all across the board so let's
see how it went here is a very nice game
Veselin Topalov versus champion Mahmoud
Arif and thank everyone for joining my
Twitter and that's Twitter sorry my
reddest feed I've created a subreddit
yesterday it's called Ivan Madar
official and I've put a link into it in
the description below if you want to
check it out already more than a
thousand people have joined the
subreddit so thank you a lot and thank
you for asking so many questions sadly
or over 500 of you have asked a question
in my AMA and I have answered most of
them I even though a lot of them were
repeated a few times but I hope I didn't
miss anyone's question but that being
said let's check it out it's it's a very
long theoretical line basically where
we're Mahmoud Europe is looking for
chances in in a line that was not played
before so let's see how it went
we have efore by top all of e5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and now Bishop to b5 as
usual the real opus and now that you
look at it
it's pretty much the same as in in Kappa
Blanc as they day and age you know in
1914 or well pretty much any tournament
we've covered you play they played the
Queens gambit declined and they played
the role up is pretty much the same as
they do today in 2019 so they you know
the old masters had it right it would
seem with a 6 more fees defense Bishop
today for Knight of 6 we have castles
and Bishop to e7 not going for the knife
captures on e4 lines same as mr. black
didn't want to capture anything against
Capablanca rook to e1 and now b5 pushing
the bishop back Bishop e3 we have d6 and
now sorry King to g1 here how did my
king get to g1 hmm that's a bit
that's a bit strange d6 and why is my
kingdom Jew oh sorry
yo I just thought I thought I castled
and then for some reason I thought I
didn't castle and okay I totally had a
breakdown here but okay
c3 by white and black castles here we
have h3 and now push up the b7 this was
it this has all been played before so
nothing new here
d4 rook to e8 and here already we have a
very interesting moment in the game
where Knight to g5 is played and now
already you can see that the f7 squares
being threatened how do you prevent it
well you have to bring your rook to f8
now here's the question was rook to e8 a
mistake if allowing Knight g5 means that
you have to go back I would rook to f8
not really because here topalov goes
back Knight to f3 and he says you should
play a different move Mammadov
but Mammadov says I'm not playing a
different move I'm gonna play rook e8
once again and you're welcome to repeat
moves now I don't know if Mahmud Arab is
actually saying that he's happy with a
draw unmoved 12 against Apollo with the
black pieces but I remember I think it
was last year in the bill chess festival
that Mahmud II are accepted the draw
with the black pieces in move eight or
something like that but yeah pretty much
everyone was very disappointed in that
especially since he's a 2,800 player
he's not now but he was a in those days
so it's a very odd I don't know if he
would accept a draw here or maybe he was
just testing to Paulo if the pollo was
interested in a draw but the pollo isn't
he plays an IBD - he doesn't repeat
Knight to g5 and okay the game continues
we have dr. fate opening up the e-file
for the rook with a three by white now
if you go Knight g5 again here after
Bishop to f8 black and just go rook to
e7 so it's not a problem for black just
to get that out there
a3 making room for the bishop on a2 and
preparing b4 we have g6 by Mahmoud ER
and now Bishop to e2 that Apollo
prepares to push b4 with Bishop to g7
and now comes b4 as planned
expanding on the queenside and here
there are a couple of moves here a five
is a known move here for black and there
is one game Fabiana Caruana versus short
italic from 2007 that ended in a draw
where Queen to d7 was played by a by
SWAT italic but here we have e captures
on d4 it's a new move in this position
and it's as a move 16 and mamedyarov
chooses a new position and okay C
captures on d4 we have a five now and
look the b1 and this is where the fun
starts
mom drf captures pawn captures on before
we have d5 now removing the defender of
the b4 pawn Knight to e5 and now just
Knight captures we have D captures on e5
there's an interesting line rook
captures on e5 top Oliver mentioned that
during the press conference after the
game but if rook captures then after
rook captures here Queen - I ate putting
a lot of pressure against the e4 pawn
but then to Paolo mentions that Bishop
to b2 would have been great and after
rook e7 Queen to a-1 and that black is
in no time to capture anything as if you
captured the bishop and g7 hangs and if
you go night h5 that this will just be
better for white but it seems that the
pall of both the parlament mama D are
missed Bishop captures on d5 which is a
long forcing variation that ends in a in
a lot of trades after Bishop captures on
f6 Bishop captures Queen captures now
you snatch up the bishop on a2 and now
you have Luke captures on b5 removing
the defender of the rook on e7 Queen
captures and not just Queen captures on
e7 and you have this position where
white is a white has a passed pawn on a5
but black is attacking a preparing to
capture also the Queen defends the c7
pawn so black doesn't really have any
problems here okay now instead of this
rook captures both of them agreed that D
captures an e5 was the correct way to go
we recapture some b4 by black now and
now c6 Mahmud our of attacks tapas very
strong Center D captures on c6 Bishop
captures and now Queen to a3 developing
the Queen and also putting yet another
defender closer to the e4 pawn and here
we have Bishop to f8 you could
simply developer rock would rock the
seat but mama deer has a different plan
bush up to f/8 piling up on the a
three-point forcing the roof to move we
have looked to be won and now comes
looked a for putting yet another
attacker in front of the d e4 pawn and
here a very interesting position if you
play something like Bishop to b2 just
keep on developing then black is gonna
go Bishop to h6 shift the bishop over to
here and White's pieces are a little bit
cramped so here instead couple of goes
about it completely different he chooses
a very active plan he decides to give up
the e4 pawn he plays nice to f1 with the
idea of free maneuvering denied over to
e3 and he wants to develop the bishop
over to g5 instead of and b2
so came I will rock captures any form
our videographer accepts the challenge
and now rook to d1 just grabbing hold of
this opened e-file attacking the Queen
we have Queen to e7 now getting out of
the way and now finally Bishop to g5
with a double attack against the night
so Bishop to g7 defending and only now
tonight's the e3 a very very brave play
by top all of putting him putting his
queen in front of the bishop like this
not afraid of any nasty discoveries but
he calculates Kurt correctly there are
no nasty discoveries for the moment so
here mommy-daughter grabbed a pawn and
he decides to grab another one Queen
captures on a three and there's nothing
wrong with this he's up two pawns now
and he does have a past beep on so if he
can just keep everything in check he
should be able to to win this and you
don't gain anything by capturing on f6
because now the bishop on e2 is hanging
so this is a top olaf's plan looked a 1
first attacking the Queen here well not
directly by threatening Bishop captures
on f7 check and then winning the Queen
so what do you do here here the best
idea is just to go back Queen to e7 and
then you go into this forcing line but
she captures Queen captures and after
rush up to d5 you are threatening some
very nice ideas after black captures we
have Queen captures you could go G
captures and now Bishop captures
and e5 would win the exchange but it
doesn't matter for example F captures on
e4 Marshall captures on e4 and here
black definitely has compensation for
the exchange he has the bishop pair and
he still has a past beep on which will
be well which will be fairly easy to
escort as you do have a bishop pair
slicing all the way across the board so
this was the the correct way to go for
black here Mahmoud era of instead went
the Queen to c5 so what's the idea here
here he's a he's hoping for Bishop
captures on f6 it's a little trap mama
decided to go for if a bunch of captures
rook a4 and just you know put that rook
in between the Queen and now you will
win back the bishop so now nothing
really happens but here after Queen to
c5 he missed one idea bite Apollo's
first the pallav goes rook beat the c1
forces the Queen to move from c5 so
where does the Queen go the Queen
doesn't move here
mama Daryl decides to move the rook by
playing rook the c4 now opening up an
attack towards top all of squeen top
Oliver moves the Queen we have Queen to
d1 and now the only way for blacks to
continue this is by playing efore this
is this is the best idea that the pond
here is very strong and although you do
you will lose the exchange you will win
back the bishop on g5 so this line will
go something like Bishop captures pawn
captures here now you have a very nice
pass pawn and now white is not in time
to remove the passed pawn because you
would lose the g5 point and okay you do
win the c6 Bishop now but then Knight
moves to h5 you open up the the dark
square Bishop for you you still have
some compensation going on but here
after Queen to d1 mom Gerald did not
play E for he played Knights to e4 and
now it simply doesn't work here I would
ask you to pause the video but there's
really no need it's it's a pretty
straightforward idea since the pawn is
not an a4 there is no attack from the
Queen towards the bishop so here mama
Daryl just played Bishop captures on c4
he grabbed he grabbed a piece a rook
we have pawn captures and here rook
captures in c4 was played and it was in
this position that chakra mama DRF
decided to resign the game why did he
resign well he's just down a full
exchange and he doesn't really have any
good compensation for it so there's
there's really no point in continuing
and so the the past pawn was basically
his only only hope of of having
something to show for for the exchange
but here without the past Ponder's
there's really you know no point in in
playing this sure now after this very
nice rook captures on c4 and move 33 a
seemingly easy victory for four top
olive but what I really enjoy here it's
it's this moment where the pall of
played after rook day for hidden just
continue developing yeah you know if you
look at this position you really don't
have a good move if you think about that
you constantly have to keep an eye on
the e4 pawn but here once again the
hardest move to find is with the knight
back the pall of place at night to f1
gives up d4 pawn which you know not
something everyone would do and he he
seemingly offers a momager of chances
for mama care of himself to go for a win
and mama deriv did so and in the end it
was the pollo who won the game it was
just a very impressive pawn sacrifice
and then he just gave up another point
here after Queen captures on a three
Brook a 1 and then here just well Bishop
captures it just unimaginable that even
our player of mama sheriff's caliber is
you know not how to say it
not craziness proof because you know
when the power place you will just you
know make things crazy and it's easy to
get lost in it but which is very
impressive for for for achieving
something against a player like mama
yarv Sam a wonderful game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jeff
graves fo CB Chess Club cassia English
Josh rogue grind rod and a bus burger
for intrusion to my channel thank you a
lot to really push
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I think all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another game from the from the Kashima
of Memorial and we will then show the
standings and check up on what's what
yeah I think y'all and I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your day